océane lecerf 13 ans est l'une des
pépites de l'étoile sportive de trappes
sa passion pour le football a commencé à
l'âge de 5 ans je voulais faire un sport
et et je trouvais que ce sport me
correspondait bien j'aime bien jouer au
ballon
j'aime bien courir après avoir foulé la
pelouse avec les garçons à ses débuts la
jeune trappistes joue aujourd'hui avec
les filles et a été surclassé chez les
moins de 16 ans s'est entraîné en l'on
installé au poste d'attaquante un choix
payant week-end dernier elle a remarqué
mode de championnat mettra plus de dix
minutes
d'accord et
un travail bien j'espère qu'il va dès
lors l after année noire
parce que pour une fille elle est
vraiment mieux techniquement c'est une
des meilleures mon groupe doué
techniquement et spécialiste des
passements de jambes la jeune trappistes
fans du psg est également assidus aux
entraînements sportifs jouent quatre
fois par semaine et n'a jamais manqué
une seule session du puy sa première
inscription
jamais un entraînement comme on croyait
les malades face à la dernière elles
étaient plâtrés elle est quand même
mieux aux entraînements elle a suivi
toute heure
toutes les filles au match tout ça elle
est partie n'est voir était tout le
temps avec lcl jouais pas après l'arrêté
non parce que ça sert à rien des
qualités qui lui permettront peut-être
d'accomplir ses rêves et de devenir
professionnel comme ses idoles marie
laure délie ou qu'il vienne mba psg à
lyon c'est des bonnes équipes et
j'imagine que je suis atteint quand j'ai
numéro 9 ou un numéro d'attaqué voilà et
aussi de finir meilleure buteuse
mais avant de viser plus haut scène veut
avant tout marqué l'histoire de trappes
la ville de son coeur et de ses débuts